dès lundi le plus haut tribunal de la
province de la Cour d'appel du Québec
entendra les arguments pour et contre la
loi québécoise sur la laïcité de l'État
la loi 21 ça sera en quelque sorte un
procès dans le procès une autre un appel
dans la pelle le débat entourant la
question des députés à l'Assemblée
nationale il y aura aussi la question
des commissions scolaires anglophones à
la Commission scolaire English Montreuil
on allaitention de se battre pour
protéger les droits des enseignantes
jusqu'en cours suprême s'il le faut pour
nous ce n'est pas une menace d'avoir une
enseignante dans une classe qui porte un
signe religieux en fait
ça démonte la diversité le Mouvement
laïque québécois est tout aussi
déterminé son objectif est que la loi
s'applique à l'ensemble des travailleurs
en position d'autorité dans la sphère
publique soit les enseignants les
policiers et les juges que la loi 21
s'applique pour l'ensemble il existe
clairement en droit constitutionnel
canadien un devoir de neutralité
religieuse pour les représentants de
l'État
dès le départ en 2019 la loi 21 avait
été adoptée dans la controverse puis en
avril 2021 un jugement de la Cour
supérieure du Québec exemptait les
commissions scolaires anglophones et les
élus de l'Assemblée nationale de la loi
21 selon le juge Marc-André Blanchard la
loi enfreint les articles 23 3 et 4 de
la Charte canadienne des droits et
libertés c'est-à-dire le droit de la
minorité anglophone de Jerry et de
contrôler ses institutions et le droit
de se porter candidat à une élection
le gouvernement du Québec on appelle du
jugement pour que la loi s'applique à
tous ceux visés par la loi sans
exception il n'y a pas deux Québec il
n'y en a qu'un seul la bataille entre
Québec et les opposants à la loi 21 est
loin d'être terminée le gouvernement
fédéral a déjà annoncé son intention de
se joindre à la contestation de la loi
21 si le dossier se rend jusqu'en cours
suprême ici Gabriel prout Radio-Canada
Montréal